no honestly it's really cool that you
can delete so much footage and then like
still like find you don't understand
honestly and I'm not I'm not kidding
right now we did this to you because
we're we're gonna delete
so you can [ __ ] learn you're about to
learn a lesson
so uh there's two Japanese companies
right one of them is called Nippon paper
the other one's called dial paper and
they're involved in a lawsuit against
each other is it like two origami
battles you know what paper company it's
close it's close they're two paper
companies what do you think they're
fighting about there's a uh basically
one company thinks the other copied them
copy the articles about paper no oh like
the the paper quality
maybe the distribution models or the
shape of the papers what's the okay
what's the most Japanese thing in the
world think think of it this way what
kind of paper do you think it's not
origami it's not origami oh was that
racist
I mean it is
recycled edamame peels oh that's pretty
good rice paper it's toilet paper oh
what do you think the idea is the
stitching the stitching no not a
stitching I have a really good idea for
toilet paper and I'm wondering if they
stole it for me you want to know what my
idea is yeah before we tell you yeah
what is it that toilet paper should come
in these kind of like cushiony pads that
like break off instead of you know this
part where you have to make them thicker
they should already be like these like
little pillows that are perforated and
then you just pull one off instead of
having to oh this part of it I like that
is that a conservationist angle for uh
it's I wasn't even taking it that way
but yes we can also weave that into the
marketing thing might be more economical
and environmentally better but I just
think it's like there's a lot of waste
but I also you know there's a lot of
room for error when you fold it yourself
yeah right yeah and saving time more
than anything right it's not that much I
always like during Shark Tank pitches
when you can tell the guy doesn't really
think something is environmentally
beneficial but he's like you know and
this is my water bottle it's great it's
also like environmentally
[Laughter]
it's like in the 90s all the food said
no trans fats yeah there's like no trans
fats yeah
so I basically dial paper is accusing uh
Nippon paper of copying their toilet
paper design which is
triple the length of a normal toilet
paper roll what just a 3X roll that's it
everyone does the three actually yeah
but they do that here that's standard
they do yeah yeah bro what are you
talking about 3x roll only sounds to me
like it's really thin toilet paper yeah
and it's like fat I'm glad you said that
because that's the actual key to have a
really good 3x roll you need to have a
specific type of way that it's rolled up
so that it doesn't uh so it'll still fit
into the thing right or else if it's
like this big yeah that means that
because most people are just going to
make it thinner but they don't they keep
it perfectly the same quality density
and they think that this company found
that secret and is now doing the same
thing yeah I need to try this toilet
paper Sherman's always talking about it
but maybe it really is folded in a
unique way where they're maximized they
believe that the technique it's like a
little crane and a little box you want a
little box it's kind of like you know
drywall like sheets of drywall you know
the way that they make those is still a
top secret really yeah what that's like
a heavily patented it's a heavily only
one place Coca-Cola formula oh really
crazy yeah because they it's a it's a
total secret how they make that come
together and not fall apart like actual
gyps never thought about it no one ever
like gave a [ __ ] so it's like what do
you think about it oh yeah like they
there's a specific way it's fused yeah
but the the method is is uh you guys
don't know how [ __ ] stupid I am but I
was using command strips for the first
time and what's command strips command
strips is like so like that's exactly
what happened to me I was like okay so
cool I'm getting velcro and I'll hang up
these pictures next to my wall right and
I was like all right so now I got these
command strips and then I attacked them
to the back of the picture right with
the little blue part and then I'm like
it's not sticking it falls off every
[ __ ] single time like great got the I
bought the world's worst velcro ever but
apparently if you if you line it up and
then you
push it together it sticks yeah but I
never encountered anything like that
it's completely smooth it's a secret
sauce you know that there's a snap
there's a secret sauce you're one step
out of me because I don't even know what
the hell you're talking about yeah it's
the next level way of hanging pictures
now yeah you don't gotta not you don't
have to make a nail in the wall [ __ ]
your walls up you just [ __ ] the
command strips and then you click it's
velcro that just you press you guys like
velcro not velcro it's like it's
completely slick and then all of a
sudden you go like it's clicks together
it's not going for where it's like you
know imagine hanging up wall art with
velcro you you just start to put it on
it's like already yeah of course
[Laughter]
if you line up exactly like you want it
and then you push it in it wow very
sweet and they have certain command
strips that can hold up to a certain
amount of weight so it's [ __ ] tight
don't [ __ ] your walls up anymore wow
[Laughter]
how many losses do you guys have to go
through like with your brand I don't
remember the last time anyone came after
us for any kind of information
um yeah sometimes it's more like an
international territories there's you
know people that are riding pretty close
to the Mark just to give you a hot tip
yeah I was gonna do this off camera but
you really should check this out I was
looking up on the break there's a
company called they're doing this this
Nike
um it's called this air sesh and They're
copying each other's ship it's so stupid
yeah they're definitely copied what are
they doing they're ripping you guys off
and you gotta put your [ __ ] letters
on it what is it can you get it in your
car after this and you can yeah air
session
and just get on those [ __ ] dude
yeah Sue the [ __ ]
it's a group of Asians with really bad
immunity
yeah I get sick all the time all the
time caught covet seven times already I
don't know what's going on
so one of the guys who's not here
because he has covered he's responsible
for the design of this shoe in a way and
they're just they're just throwing them
under the bus hardcore yo Ryan what are
you talking about dude that's not why so
we kept trying to help out we keep
talking [ __ ] about kinjas yeah one of
the other castmates he's like the leader
of the king just and they helped Nike
develop their new dance shoe okay so
that's what you start air sessions so
feel free to litigate sure no discretion
let's see so that's never had even in
the beginning nobody ever came after you
to try to shut you down uh to shut us
down no we there's a chapter in my book
where I talk about American eagle
stealing this character the atom bomb
and then uh you know we went up against
him and it was just betting on a phone
like making all kinds of wild threats
and they caved just like a really cool
because because we're lawyers but we
also we also just were like we had
nothing to lose we were such a small
company and they're this massive company
and they're making all these threats and
whatever and so we actually like put
them on hold and I was just like why
don't we just tell them that we're gonna
put them on blast and we have nothing
and they were like you can't do that and
we're like okay we will and then they
were finally like all right we'll just
donate all of them they got rid of the
product and done wow because the threat
in my world is you're gonna be sleeping
with a fish and save yeah
you are turning into the penguin
City again now a lot of people steal or
are you know they rip or Petty or
inspired by stuff that we do and that
happens all the time in the street where
I rarely care I rarely can't because
people are like oh that looks exactly
like your T-shirt or you already did
that the God hates and like you're
blaming it the Paisley is they're doing
it and I'm like inspiration comes from
everywhere I was inspired by you know
for a lot of us we in our generation we
have all the same cultural touch points
we listen to the same music we're all
from this we're the same we're all
connected so that's special yeah I'm
like okay you stole that one I have 10
000 more ideas in the bag like you can
have that you know but American eagle
stealing it's kind of whack though that
is right well that becomes a problem
because most people now they have such a
further footprint bigger footprint than
us so most people now are associating
that bomb with their brand and thinking
it's there so then when they see ours
coming up they're like oh that's like an
American Eagle so that's where you have
to actually have to draw the line right
but if it's just like so you guys are
still alive and they're not so haha I
think they are still alive actually yeah
I think I actually think they're bigger
than ever
yeah yeah I don't think so their Factory
shot down I think they did a stock split
and everyone made even more money
they're doing so well
yeah I didn't stop it how rigid are some
of these Brands like if you're working
like with like the Rams or something
like that like are they just like
there's no room for creativity it's the
Rams mother yeah yeah yeah most licensed
projects the bigger Brands and companies
Disney Sports especially because a lot
of those like old boy clubs where
they're like we don't want anyone
messing with this right they don't even
want to do it a lot of like like
personalities artists they just also
don't want people interfering with art
so a lot of them are pretty they're
strict they're really strict like even
with we were working on more stuff with
the NBA and at a certain point we just
decided not to do it because they were
like you can't make anything that even
looks like a basketball jersey wow like
in your collection and we're like well
I'd rather just not work with the NBA at
that point right and so what about horse
jockey pants first hockey pants could be
good I feel like they'd be and it says
Phoenix Suns right here
happy
birthday